thanks to nebula for sponsoring this
video this video is an introduction to
something you've almost certainly heard
of but might not know very much about so
what is El Nino El Nino refers to this
current of warm water that appears off
the west coast of South America from
time to time but confusingly when people
talk about elino they could be referring
to this current or more likely one of
two connected things the first is the
elino southern oscillation which is one
of the most incredible things on earth
and this current is just part of Eno for
short is a system of coupled changes in
the Pacific Ocean and the atmosphere
over it changes in how the winds blow
over the Pacific Ocean leads to changes
in how water moves around in the ocean
which changes the temperature of the
ocean which then changes how winds flow
over the Pacific we tend to describe
that coupled system as being in one of
three states that it flips between
basically randomly every couple of years
the neutral state is the long-term
average where things are doing what they
normally do the trade winds blow from
east to west across the Pacific rising
up in the west and forming a closed loop
underneath that Loop ocean water is also
transported east to west which gets
heated by the equatorial sun and the
result is a West Pacific that's warmer
and wetter than the East Pacific the
second state is called the lania state
in linia years stronger trade winds blow
this causes more warm water to move
Westward and the West Pacific is warmer
than usual over in the East cold water
from the deep ocean Wells up to replace
the water that traveled to the West so
the West Ocean is warmer than usual and
the East ocean is colder than usual
causing the stronger Trade Winds
basically a more intense version of
neutral conditions the third state
though is the El Nino State and when
people talk about elino this is what
they're normally referring to during an
elino event everything gets Disturbed
and the Eastern Pacific can warm up and
because of that the trade winds which
are kind of maintaining this East West
gradient are weakened the rainfall can
move over the Central and even into the
East Pacific and this messes with the
circulation in the atmosphere and in the
ocean and this causes a massive
reorganization of the global climate
system the elinia sto is a very
different Beast not just the opposite of
lania but it can also be much more
intense the Waters of the Eastern
Pacific can be several degrees warmer
and rainfall patterns shift massively to
the east this can be an enormous change
for basically the entire ocean Basin so
just a recap El Nino refers to this
current of warm water that appears in
the El Nino Southern oscillation climate
system when it is in the El Nino phase I
know it's a bit confusing just remember
that elino means warm Pacific Ocean so
why does n so flip between those States
it's important to understand that it's
not as simple as the atmosphere forces
the ocean or the ocean forces the
atmosphere we cannot say whether a
change in one of those two parts of the
system will cause the whole system to
flip State the atmosphere in the ocean
are tight coupled and we don't exactly
know why they flip between those two
states some people will say that the
system is just inherently unstable like
it's an unstable oscillator that bounces
between elino and linia with some
returning force that restores it to a
neutral State other theory is that it's
the system is relatively neutral but
it's being kicked around all time with
noise so it's kind of like a stochastic
oscillator and I still don't know I
still don't know if we understand which
one it is these numbers on the screen by
the way are references they're linked
down in the description if you would
like to read further on this topic or
other topics in this video so why is Al
Nino important there are two big reasons
why alino is so important firstly the
Pacific Ocean is huge and so natural
changes in its average temperature will
have a large impact on global average
temperature we'll come back to that but
secondly and in my opinion much more
interestingly whether Eno is in a linia
or an alino phase has huge impacts
literally around the world as I
mentioned previously the rainfall is
normally in the West Pacific associated
with rainfall you have a huge amount of
heating of the atmosphere because of the
the latent heat fusion of water so that
when the water condenses in the in the
clouds and fall Falls as rain it
releases a lot of heat and that heating
Source in the atmosphere triggers waves
waves here just means patterns of
alternating areas of high and low
pressure or temperature that then can
move through the atmosphere wave is just
what we call that in atmospheric science
and they're kind of a big deal and if
you start shifting around where the
rainfall is then you're going to change
where the source of these waves are and
you're going to change weather as far
away as the South Pole for example we
call this changing of the weather at a
distance a teleconnection and there are
lots of them on Earth but Eno is the
biggest and most important if the
Pacific is in an elino state or a linia
state that makes certain weather
conditions more likely in other areas of
the world for example in elnino years
it's more likely that the Indian Monsoon
will be weaker and there'll be more
wildfires in Indonesia it also makes it
more likely that the Amazon will be
drier than usual but no two El ninos are
the same and there's no guarantee of its
impact so for example uh you would
expect to see dry Northern Australia
during an alino event in the big 97 98
Al event Northern Australia was wet and
no one really understood why that was
the case I previously did a whole video
on how El Nino might have caused the
downfall of entire civilizations in the
past link up on on the screen and down
in the description and of course I
mention it in my book firmament ideal
Christmas present is El Nino connected
to climate change and so and the El Nino
state within it are entirely natural
phenomena they would occur whether
humans were here or not but El Nino is
still a really important topic within
climate science firstly as already
mentioned the state of Eno has a huge
impact on natural Global temperature
changes there are lots of reasons why
the average temperature of the planet
might change entirely naturally
including Eno but also other things like
the mad Julian oscillation in the Indian
Ocean but also random one-off events
like volcanoes erupting spewing sulfates
into the air reflect sunlight away
temporarily cooling the Earth total
natural temperature changes over the
past Century look like this and human
influence temperature changes from
burning fossil fuels and other
activities look like this when we
combine them we get the observed change
in global temperature and while the
human influence dominates over the whole
Century natural changes are really
important year-to year and explain why
we don't break the record for Global
temperature every year for example 2016
was for a long time the warmest J on
record because of a huge warm
temperature anomaly that year from you
guessed it the Pacific being in an El
Nino phase this year we expect to be the
new warmest year on record with the
temperature anomaly up to December being
somewhere between 1.4 and 1.5° c and
that is because of human influence but a
large part of the increase from last
year is because the Pacific went from
being in a long linia phase into an El
Nino phase and so when we leave this
elino phase global average temperatures
will fall slightly but just to be very
clear just because this curve goes down
this curve still a really big problem
but an interesting question is is eno
and elino changing because of climate
change and Matt was one of the lead
authors on a huge paper that came out on
this subject two years ago in the
journal Nature up until recently it was
difficult to answer this question
because scientists were looking at how
the sea surface temperature part of
their new was changing in different
predictions of the future by different
climate models but remember Eno also has
that rainfall component if you look at
the the rainfall
changes um they seem pretty robust
across models so all the models were
telling us the same thing in the future
the rainfall is Shifting further
eastwards more often so if you measure
start measuring Eno in terms of the
shift in the rainfall pattern you get
this more consistent picture of
increases in extreme events and more
frequent uh elinos actually that that
metric is actually more important in
terms of the teleconnections because you
know the as we spoke about previously
the atmospheric heating is associated
where the convection sits so on a warmer
planet we expect Eno to flip between
linia and ELO States more frequently and
that will result in Greater variability
of weather all over the planet there's
also the possibility that there may be
an increase in the frequency of Elia
years specifically According to some of
the models you'd think that you could
compare those model predictions with
what we've observed over the past couple
of decades to see if the models are
right but honestly we don't have enough
data the system only flips every couple
of years and we need longer to see if
there's been any change in the long-term
statistics One Way Or Another We're all
going to find out whether the models are
right together so elino is a current of
warm water in the Eastern Pacific Ocean
but much more than that whether the
Pacific Ocean atmosphere system is in an
alino or linia phase has huge impact on
the rest of the World's temperature
rainfall and much more it directly
impacts the average temperature of the
Earth on top of the anthropogenic
warming signal like so many parts of our
planet it is beautiful it's this duet
between the atmosphere and the ocean but
also like many beautiful parts of our
planet our influence as humans is
growing and we still have much to
understand about it but hopefully now
you know at least the basics now let me
tell you a quick story at the end of my
PhD before started making videos
full-time I went to VidCon Amsterdam and
I met a bunch of incredible people
including some amazing educational
creators like real engineering went over
Productions and real life law and later
that year just after submitting my
thesis actually I found myself in New
York and I was asked if I'd like to join
that group of creators in building
something at first we just worked
together in securing sponsors for our
videos an agency but we wanted to build
something more we wanted to build
something something where we could post
our videos and not have to worry about
sponsors or advertising in general and
Netflix for educational video but owned
by us the creators that something became
nebula and over the years we've gone
from success to success we've produced
original series like becoming human
taboo on screen and extremities we've
produced original films like Patrick
Willams Knight of the coconut and Abby
Thorns the prince this year we hit
2third of a million active users and
it's not an exaggeration to say that
nebula is changing the way the online
video is financed away from advertisers
and towards audiences putting control
back in the hands of creators more than
half a million people currently enjoy
the benefits of nebula watching videos
before they are published on YouTube
able to download videos to their devices
and with access to exclusive content
I've made several original videos and
companion videos to projects on YouTube
and you can watch them all on my nebula
page I've also made an entire class on
how to tell tell stories about science
on nebula Meeting those creators in
Amsterdam changed my life and nebula has
changed my life it's changed the way
that Finance works for us creators and I
think going forwards it's going to have
a bigger and bigger influence on The
Wider internet to be part of that and
get access to everything nebula has to
offer you can sign up at go.
nebula.com offer you can get for
yourself or as a gift for a friend
lifetime membership we're offering this
to raise money for huge projects that
we're filming next year I'm just not
allowed to say what they are just yet
but I can say that it's taking nebula to
the next stage of financing Creator
projects as previously we didn't want to
be beholden to outside investors we
wanted to be beholden to our audience
and so we're offering you lifetime
membership and you in exchange never
have to worry about managing your
subscription ever again lifetime
membership is a one-off payment of $300
and will give you access to nebula for
as long as both you and we are around
that link again was go.
nebula.com patrons patrons get early
access to videos they can vote on a
video topic a month and they get
exclusive access to a behind thes scenes
monthly Vlog executive producer patrons
are the people that you are seeing on
the screen right now and if you'd like
to join them please do head to
patreon.com Ox Fizz Linked In the
description let me know what you thought
of this format I'd like to do more
videos like this on key features of the
Earth system let me know your thoughts
down in the comments and if you like the
video please do also pop it a like
here's some recommendations for your
next video and that just leades me to
say thank you for watching I'll see you
in the next one